So welcome to Artificial Intelligence for Robotics.
You are entering an exciting 7-week class
in which you'll learn how to program self-driving cars.
And just to motivate what we're trying to achieve in this class,
let me show you some videos.
My interest in self-driving cars started with the DARPA Grand Challenge in 2004
in which my team at Stanford developed Stanley,
a robot that could drive itself through the Mojave Desert.
The vehicle was based on a Volkswagen Touareg
that was equipped with all kinds of sensors like GPS and laser,
and it was able to make its own decisions without any human input whatsoever.
The DARPA Grand Challenge was a government-sponsored race
that took place in 2005.
Here we see our robot Stanley moving through the desert
completely without a human on board.
The task was to drive a desert trail for about 130 miles,
and whoever was fastest would win the race.
Here we're passing a different robot by Carnegie Mellon University
about 110 miles into the race.
Our robot was able to navigate really steep mountainous roads
and able to avoid collisions with rocks or falling down a cliff
all based on its ability to use what I'm going to teach you in this class.
After almost 7 hours and 131 miles our robot returned all the way to the starting base
as the first robot to ever finish a DARPA Grand Challenge
winning Stanford University 2 million bucks
and Stanley a place in the Smithsonian Museum of American History.
This work led to the Urban Challenge, in which we built another robot called Junior
that eventually took second place.
The Urban Challenge was a followup race by DARPA
in which cars were asked to drive in traffic,
so whereas the Grand Challenge was kind of a motionless desert floor,
this was a mock urban city where the robot was able to interact with other traffic
and had to follow the traffic rules as in this left turn over here.
It had to be stay on lanes with very high precision,
accommodate oncoming traffic and just drive confidently
in a situation that really resembled a small city.
This led at Google to a sequence of experiments
known as the Google self-driving car.
I believe these are the best robotic cars out there today.
Here we see one of our Priuses on University Avenue in Palo Alto
they are undetected, driving just like a human driver,
but this car was driving by itself.
Our cars have been able to drive hundreds of thousands of miles
all across California and some of Nevada,
in downtown areas like San Francisco, on busy highways.
Here in Monterey, a small coastal city in California with lots and lots of pedestrians.
These are all completely self-driving moments where the car is able to accommodate
things like deer in the headlights in the middle of the night
or even crooked Lombard Street in San Francisco as shown in this video.
This is what I'm doing on my day job.
I really love, with my team, building self-driving cars.
We believe it's going to really change the world,
and in this class that's what I hope to enable you to do.
Let's dive in.